Es klingt total verrückt aber es könnte tatsächlich sein dass wir bald keine
sauerstoffflaschen mehr unter wasser benötigen wie soll das gehen und können wir auch flüssigkeit statt luft atmen
bord klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Vielen dank für diesen mega spannenden dem vorschlag über whatsapp ja ein forschungsteam aus dänemark hat ein neuartiges
kristall material entwickelt das zum großteil aus kobalt besteht die chemische verbindung
namens aquaman christel soll große mengen an sauerstoff aus der luft aufnehmen können und bei bedarf aber auch wieder
abgeben das metall kobalt führt dazu dass sauerstoff überhaupt erst aufgenommen werden kann auch im menschlichen körper
der kobalt im übrigen nicht selbst herstellen kann spielt ist so eine wichtige rolle es muss über atemluft wasser oder nahrung
aufgenommen werden aber nur in sehr kleinen mengen denn sonst kann es wiederum
gesundheitsschädigend wirken das besondere das kristall gibt den sauerstoff ohne druck oder erhitzung frei dabei ändert sich die farbe
ist das kristall gesättigt mit sauerstoff ist es dunkel blau bis schwarz
wenn es den sauerstoff abgibt färbt es sich rosa dazu eine der beteiligten forscherinnen
christin mckenzie
das material ist sowohl sender als auch container für sauerstoff wir können uns verwenden um ihn aufzunehmen zu speichern und zu transportieren
aufgrund dieser eigenschaften
kann man es als eine art
künstliches hämoglobin betrachten das dänische forschungsteam glaubt dass die kristalle effektiver sein als eine sauerstoffflasche
denn einige körnchen des materials sollen schon den sauerstoffgehalt eines mittelgroßen
raums speichern können wir genau bei tauchern eingesetzt werden könnte das ist noch nicht klar
eine überlegung wäre die kristalle einfach in den mund zu nehmen
spannend wäre das ganz natürlich nicht nur für taucher sondern eben überall wo wir menschen auf sauerstoff angewiesen sind im weltall
beispielsweise aber auch für patienten die noch an
sauerstoffgeräte angebunden sind wäre dies eine denkbare lösung auf den markt gebracht wurde das sauerstoff kristall bisher allerdings noch nicht
eine komplett andere sache die man aber auch aus science fiction filmen kennt ist das atmen durch
verschiedene flüssigkeiten mit wasser ist das nicht möglich dafür aber mit flüssigkeiten in denen sowohl
sauerstoff als auch kohlendioxid sehr gut löslich ist so genannte perfluorcarbon
denn für die atmung von organismen ist es nicht wirklich wichtig ob flüssigkeit oder luft geatmet wird hauptsache
es wird genug sauerstoff zugeführt und
kohlendioxid abtransportiert versuche dazu gab es schon in den 60er jahren als ein forschungsteam aus den usa mäuse für mehr als 17 stunden
in eine flüssigkeit tauchten ohne dass die tiere erstickten sie
atmeten wirklich ausschließlich über die sie umgebende flüssigkeit mittlerweile ist die sogenannten flüssigkeits beatmung auch wichtig im medizinischen bereich
beispielsweise bei frühgeborenen babys mit unreifen lungen oder auch patientinnen und patienten mit akutem lungen versagen dabei werden die lungen
vollständig mit einer perfluorcarbon
flüssigkeit gefüllt die durch ein spezielles
beatmungsgerät mit sauerstoff angereichert und dass abgeordnete
kohlendioxid entfernt wird ich stelle es mir echt ein bisschen
spooky vor und zwar beide ideen mit steinchen im mund und dann sicher zu sein dass der sauerstoff ausreicht oder die lungen voller flüssigkeit zu
haben und zu atmen ja mal schauen wann es die ersten anwendungen für beide fälle für uns otto
normalverbraucher gibt so dass wir das wirklich erleben können
wenn ihr keine videos dazu und zu allen anderen dem verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp darum geht ihr die kaputte abo boxee auf
youtube und verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen anderen also ich schicke euch vorher eine nachricht vom neuesten video
täglich
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks um social and media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus social media welt dafür
da klicken aber nicht die genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch drauf klicken können wir unsterblich werden
human enhancement bis dann
bleibt dran